hey this is fresh talker this problem is
going viral right now and it's being
shared with the claim that only a genius
could solve it and that 99% fail many
people are arguing about what the
correct answer is in this video I'm
going to explain what many people
believe to be the correct answer
can you figure it out give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for the solution so
before you start computing the final
answer you should look very closely at
the last line the shape are different
from the shape in the previous line for
example the clock in the final line
shows two o'clock but in the previous
line it shows three o'clock furthermore
the bananas in the final line have
bunches of three bananas as compared to
the other bunches in the equations which
have four bananas finally the last shape
has only 11 edges compared to the other
shape in the figures which has 15 edges
so in order to solve this problem we're
going to have to figure out numerical
values that we can figure out and apply
to the final line so let's try and see
if there's any logical structures to
these equations we'll start out with the
first equation we have three of these
shapes which are equal to 45 this
simplifies to one hexagon being equal to
15 however it's not just a hexagon if
you look closely at the shape it
consists of the hexagon which has six
edges a Pentagon which has five edges
and a square which has four edges we're
going to have to figure out a value for
the edges in order that we can figure
out a value for the shape in the final
line so we can simplify this if we count
the total number of edges this shape has
15 edges and it's equal to 15 so we can
conclude that one
is equal to one will take this
information and use this to solve the
next equation we can replace the hexagon
figure with the value of 15 that we just
figured out we now have two bunches of
bananas that will be equal to 23 minus
15 which is eight we can simplify that a
single bunch of bananas is equal to four
now look closely at this bunch of banana
there are four bananas in the bunch and
that's equal to four so that would
simplify to mean one banana is equal to
one we'll take this information and use
it to solve the next equation we have a
bunch of four bananas which we know will
be equal to four we're adding that to
two o'clock would show three o'clock and
that's going to be equal to ten when we
take ten minus four we get sick so we
have two o'clock showing three o'clock
that's equal to six we can simplify that
one o'clock showing three o'clock is
equal to three now since three o'clock
is equal to three that would suggest
that each hour is equal to one we now
have the information needed to evaluate
the last line we start out with the
clock that shows two o'clock since each
hour is equal to one we can assign a
value of two here we now have a bunch of
bananas
where each bunch has three bananas so
each banana is equal to one we can say
each bunch has a value of three we
finally have a shape and there are 11
edges in total to the shape we're
missing the square from the previous
figure in the earlier equation since
each edge is equal to 1 11 edges would
be equal to 11 so we're now ready to
evaluate this expression but we have to
remember one more thing we have a
multiplication in this equation so we
need to evaluate that first
Accor
to the order of operation three times 11
is equal to 33 we have two plus three
plus 33 so what's our final answer two
plus three plus 33 is equal to 38 and
that's the answer to this puzzle did you
figure it out thanks for watching this
video please subscribe to my channel I
make videos on mass in game theory you
can catch one on my blog mind your
decisions that you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at pressure
Walker and if you liked this video
please check out my book there are links
in the video description